do we have any idea how much Russian
money there is sloshing around here in
the UK we've got some estimates of the
dirty money money that there are the
proceeds of corruption or other illicit
money and it's estimated estimated by
the National Crime Agency to be around a
hundred billion a year in total of which
possibly a quarter is from Russia
goodness a quarter is from Russia yeah
and where are the other sources of this
sort of money there multifarious around
the world I mean we've tracked property
in London bought by dirty money from
Azerbaijan Nigeria Pakistan pretty much
all over but Russia is a particular sort
of hotspot in terms of London now the
risk of without labelling any particular
financial institutions where where are
the conduits in into the city from how
does this money get here the major banks
are conduits as you'd expect but what's
interesting is by the time it gets to
London it's sometimes whizzed all around
the world through multiple financial
centers and particularly complicit of
the UK's overseas territories like the
British Virgin Islands and the Crown
Dependencies places like the Isle of Man
and Jersey and so on because it's so
easy to get money through there and hide
it and that's despite various drives by
various governments to increase
transparency in some of these Crown
Dependencies yeah I mean the
government's talk to sort of as a
difficult game on this that they're
aware that those centres depend on large
financial flows and so they haven't put
as much pressure on them as they might
to clean up their act they don't operate
to the standards you see in London on
transparency for example what how does
London shape up compared with other
major financial centres around the world
the likes of Hong Kong Singapore New
York they're around half a dozen centres
including the ones you mentioned which
are real focal points for dirty money
flowing around the world London has
certain advantages Russians have always
found but London particularly attractive
and other jurisdictions will attract
others so China will go particularly for
Hong Kong as you'd expect Indian money
option often goes to Dubai but Russia
has often come to London London has
certain advantages it has these historic
links with the Crown Dependencies and
overseas territory so it's very easy to
be part of that sort of global
laundering system it's also a huge
market in itself so if you want to hide
the dirty money it's easier to do
amongst all the clean
what when we talk about this term dirty
money what do we mean by that money that
has been illicit ly procured yeah so it
could be the proceeds of organized crime
or the proceeds of corruption if you pay
a bribe of 10 million pounds to get a
contract where do you want to keep the
10 million pounds probably not in Russia
you park it in a house in Kensington
right all right
and I mean you mentioned that you
alluded to this remotely I mean just how
did London become such a playground for
wealthy Russians I mean this wasn't an
accident
no I mean partly I think the UK has
deliberately courted foreign money and
certainly after the financial crisis for
example there was a visa regime where if
you pitched up with one or two million
pounds you could simply buy a visa
called an investment visa with no
questions asked now they've tightened up
that system but there are thousands of
people who got through and have never
been checked properly worth pointing out
other countries do this I mean the
Portuguese quite keen on that sort of
setup as well aren't they how the
country certainly do it and in
Portugal's case for example Angola with
the historic link so often that money
often goes to Portugal but London has
been a particular magnet because of its
size the luxury goods it provides the
private education the PR agencies that
can launder your reputation